LAKSHYA: Hi friends.
I am Lakshya
Siyaramakrishnan, and I'm here
to walk you through my
journey with technology.
You can follow me here on my G+
and Twitter handle so that we
can get in touch.
Let me introduce myself to you.
Born in Mumbai, the city of
dreams, a native of Kerala,
the place with the highest
literacy rate, a Tamil speaking
girl brought up in
Karnataka, the land
of sandlewood, scenic
beauty, and splendid people.
I have been fortunate to
see many flavors of India.
And you get to see
our diversity here.
I am a woman tech maker, a
design engineer by profession,
a unicorn and
connector by passion.
I'll tell you why I
call myself a unicorn,
but you'll have to wait
for me to get there.
I call myself a connector.
You want to know why?
That's because I love
connecting to people around me.
Connectors bring about
change through people.
And that's exactly what
I am here to do today.
I am here to bring about
change through you.
I am here to bring about change
through woman tech makers.
I want you and me to be
instrumental in bringing
about this change.
So let's do this together.
Let's close our
eyes for a moment.
Can we do that together please?
Imagine an engineer.
Have you done that?
How many of us visualized
a man coding on his laptop?
Many of us would have
done that, for sure.
Or did you think of a woman?
Or even better, is it you?
How many of us think
of ourselves when we
have to visualize an engineer?
Hardly a few.
And this is exactly
where the problem lies.
One of the biggest
problems is that we
doubt our own capabilities.
Technology is touching our
lives right from our cradles
to our graves, and having
a woman's perspective
in prototyping, designing,
and implementing
is equally important.
Statistics say that
if a man and a woman
are given an unknown
task, a man is 90%--
I repeat, 90%
confident of committing
to do it, whereas
a woman instantly
doubts her capabilities.
Why is there this mismatch?
Why are we losing out on
seizing the opportunity?
Not many things that happen
in your childhood stays
imprinted in your minds a
few decades down the lane.
But I clearly remember
the first time
I got associated
with technology.
I had to prepare for my computer
science lab best way back
in school when I was around
six, seven years old,
and we did not have
a computer at home.
My father accompanied
me to a cyber cafe
quite some distance away for
me to practice my lessons
for the exam.
And when I went there,
I saw this lady typing
onto this machine at
quite an amazing speed.
I was so amazed by
the typing speed
that I told my father about it.
My father was happy at my awe
and said, in a few years time,
you'll be able to
do it much faster.
A few months later, he
got me a computer at
home so that I'd get
there soon enough.
Reaching out for what we
don't have and getting it
is always a good start.
At that age, it
was amazing for me
to see a machine being
able to do so many things.
Once I got the
computer at home, I
started exploring and
experimenting new things on it.
Creating a PowerPoint
presentation
gave me a lot of satisfaction.
I remember the time when my
father took me to his office
one day and allowed
me to use his system,
and I came up with this
beautiful PowerPoint
presentation and handed
it over to his boss.
And for a kid of that
age, it was a real sense
of accomplishment to
be patted on your back
by your dad's boss.
User interface was always
dear to me, and it still is.
I love designing web
pages at my leisure
on the themes of my choice.
So listen to me when I
tell you, do what you love,
and you would love what you do.
It's very essential that we look
to build of any strong support
system around ourselves
to get to the top.
My teachers and my parents
always supported me.
The teachers always
pushed me to achieve more.
They used to tell me that I
have to be better than the best
to shine in life, to
make a mark in life.
And similar scenes
were seen at home.
If I come back home with
a 99 in math-- trust me,
this has happened two
or three times at home--
my mother would first ask me
where I lost that one mark,
and then give me credit
for the 99 that I've got.
And that zeal to score a
perfect 100 in as many places as
possible really helped me.
This even got me the best
student award at school.
So that is why I tell
you it's so essential
to build a strong support
system for ourselves.
At no point in this journey
did I visualize myself
as an engineer.
I did not know about a career
called software engineering.
I knew only of two careers--
a doctor and a teacher,
and I always wanted
to be a doctor.
So as I was getting out
of school at crossroads
deciding career paths,
a teacher of mine
suggested that I
take up engineering.
She knew how much I
loved math and science,
and life often throws
us into situations
where we need to make a choice.
I made the choice.
I said, I want to
be an engineer,
and I followed my heart.
I got into one of the
premier engineering colleges
in Karnataka and
learned my lessons well.
And over this journey of four
years, the passion in the field
further strengthened.
I wanted to try out new things.
And as I completed my four years
of engineering, I realized,
hey, four years have
passed, and I've not
done anything hands on.
I know my theory well, but it's
time to put this into practice.
At that time, I decided
that pursuing a masters
would be the best thing to do.
Again, following your heart.
I applied to
universities across India
and go into one,
where life turned out
to be better than
I thought it would.
I got the best
hands-on experience
with some great faculty, some
great people, good projects,
and above all, great learning.
We always say we hardly
have women in technology.
But let me give you
a contradiction.
We were one of the very few
masters of technology batches,
probably in the country,
to have more numbers
of girls than guys in a class.
Girls were at a 51 to 49 ratio.
But then, what goes wrong?
The girls are really good.
They attend all their classes,
dutifully write down notes,
get great grades.
But when it comes to
going above and beyond,
when it comes to exploring
and experimenting,
we often take a backseat.
I remember a time
when I had to attend
a hackathon outside college.
A few of my male friends
agreed to accompany me,
but not a single
girl put her hand up.
So when I told my mother
about this, she was like,
what are you going to do
with all the guys there?
Fortunately, this
did not put me off,
and I continued
attending these events.
So let me ask you
that today, we have
to look to alter this phenomenon
to get more women sitting
at the table.
Right from the very
beginning, I was
someone who seized
every opportunity,
and that's the way I
had been brought up.
Remember I told you
about the support system?
This was where I was getting to.
My parents always
encouraged me to take up
any activity that came
my way, and the concept
of participation was far
more important than winning.
I was fortunate to
be a part of the YMCA
Mumbai for a few weeks.
I had been the head girl
and the valedictorian way
back in school.
I was part of the
student's activity council
and the Google student
club at my master's degree.
I've done a lot of computing
and event management
in school, colleges, and
even at my workplace.
They call me an energizer
in my workplace.
Oh, that reminds me,
I have to tell you
why I am called the unicorn.
Time to unravel
that mystery now.
No, it's not the same
animal that we know about.
I'm a part of the GDG
BlrDroid community
and help them
organize events there.
Again, I just love doing this,
and I went on to do that.
So they call me a unicorn.
I don't know why,
but I know what's
common between me
and the unicorn.
We both follow what we
love doing the most.
And just like how I got
inspired by being a unicorn,
I want to take you all there,
ensuring that we are all
following our passions.
So that was about me.
But I am here for
a bigger purpose,
to help contribute
to the community
and inspire you to do the same.
I know there are many
classes like mine
with more numbers of girls than
boys in a professional course.
But it's time we make an impact.
It's time that we look
to bridge this confidence
gap by believing in
ourselves, by taking risks,
by doing what we love the most.
I imagine a perfect
world where there
are equal number of men
and women sitting a table,
brainstorming together,
innovating and inventing
together, and most importantly,
leading a group of people
by inspiring them.
There will be many people
throwing stones at you,
but let's learn to
silence critics and say,
I can do much better
than this, and look
to convert these
stones into milestones.
I'm sure we'll be reaching
places by doing this.
We'll figure out how to take
this to a larger extent.
But for now, let's make
a promise to ourselves.
Let's look to attend all
developer events that
are happening across the city,
learn from them, teach a few,
and contribute back
to the community.
Today, if everyone
watching this video
works towards
keeping this promise,
I think we will get to hear
more women voices out there.
We will get to see more women on
the team, sitting at the table.
Remember the time
when we were little
and we had no baggage
on our shoulders?
When we did what
we loved the most?
When we would connect to
as many people as possible,
just to have a game together?
Let's get back to
that mode again.
Let's stop being
at the side lines.
Let's change the
rules of the game.
Be heard.
Be seen.
Be at the table.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Thank you.